awesome thanks chief I'll take it from
here alright thanks Kelly thanks for
khari I have the pleasure of helping
moderate this incredible panel today so
let's introduce our players to you first
up we have Catherine Gluckstein who is
the GM of project x cloud responsible
for product and strategy now we're gonna
have Jason Ronald the director of
program management for the Xbox platform
we've got Rachel Card senior director of
program management for Microsoft gaming
and rounding things out is gonna be
Chris Novak partner and head of Xbox
design studio everyone welcome cool can
we hear everybody you guys on on the
phone hello hi everybody
okay so got a couple ground rules today
again everybody we're doing this live so
this is gonna be a lot of fun but as
ground rules just because we have
everybody that is going to be on picture
but no video we're gonna do a little bit
of listening actions here so I'm going
to be asking questions and I'm gonna try
and ask a question directly to a person
so when you guys get that just give a
second pause so we can make sure I'm not
speaking over each other but we're gonna
do the best we can so with that before
we get into the meat of the topics I
want to give some context as to why each
of you were chosen to be with us today
Catherine let's start with you before X
cloud you serve this Phil Spencer's
chief of staff bringing with you more
than 20 years of product experience how
does that prepared you to step into this
leadership role so firstly Brian I just
want to say I wish I could be there in
person but as you know all our worlds
have been turned upside down by this
this crazy virus and in fact I've got
two kids in another room doing home
schooling and my husband on meetings
elsewhere so I'm just fingers crossed my
Internet's gonna stand up but what
prepared me for this role so you know
really I've spent the last 20 years
building a career that has sort of
harness technology to evolve the
distribution consumption and business
models for content and then about three
years ago weight as you rightly said I
joined Xbox as bill Spencer's chief of
staff and I have to say that was an
incredible experience
I mean fail as we know is one of
gaming's greats he might blush if I
say that but it's but you know to have
the experience to learn about gaming
you know alongside him was just gave me
you know incredible insight into where
this business is going and as you know
Brian we spent a lot of time looking to
evolve the Xbox strategy during that
period it was where we stated our goal
was to reach the two billion gamers on
the planet and we defined our framework
as the three C's the content community
and cloud and you know as you can see
I'm lucky enough now to get to execute
this strategy with an amazing team you
know really get to execute on that third
C the cloud strategy so couldn't feel
luckier awesome awesome Thank You
Catherine Jason let's go to you you're
part of the core team on Xbox series X
and before that you were with the Xbox
advanced technology group and Xbox game
studios now you've had a front row seat
to much of the evolution happening in
the industry how has that influenced the
way that you lead teams around Xbox
series X thanks Brian
you know really this is one of the most
exciting times in my long history in the
game industry with the introduction of
like new disruptive technologies
innovative game design and just totally
new ways to engage with players so I
think first and foremost it's really
about listening to our customers and
when I say customers I mean both gamers
and developers the voice of the
development community is absolutely
critical to everything that we do here
in team Xbox and it really kind of
shapes where we take the technology and
the platforms that we deliver and as a
platform builder and designer our role
is really to empower developers to
deliver on their creative visions but by
providing them with the best hardware
software and development tools and we
really want the technology to fade away
for both developers and players so the
gamers have the most amazing and
immersive experience on whatever device
they choose to play on mmm that's
awesome Rachel let's go over to you you
have experience working with the
governor of South Carolina and you also
led an indie video game studio how has
your background giving you maybe a
unique perspective as the product we get
for Xbox series X hey Brian thanks for
that you
so I have a really unique background and
first I think I would just like to
acknowledge I feel very very fortunate
for the experiences that I've had both
in my education and in my professional
roles the red thread kind of across all
those is that I've had the honor to work
with really great people and do really
great things where when I worked with
the indie game studio when we formed
that it was really amazing experiences
for gamers and really digging deep to
understand what would delight them and
what experiences they would love it was
also about getting sold on the value of
entrepreneurial spirit and agility and
those skills I bring with me when I
worked with the governor that was really
humbling it was an awesome experience
you know we were on a personal mission
both of us to increase job opportunities
to help you know a really difficult
public education system and our beloved
home state and so my current role now
you know Microsoft it's our mission to
strive to empower every person and every
organization on the planet and I think
we're really fortunate to be in a
position to help do that and so for me
when I think about product I'm grateful
for my experiences but really I'm most
grateful for all of my team experiences
because I think we all have very
individual unique experiences that shake
the products we build these products are
a reflection of the team that build them
and we believe that in our core that's
good that's good now Chris let's finish
with you real quick you are a game
designer by trade with over 25 years
experience in the industry now you've
shipped titles like Forza Motorsport
Project Gotham Racing crackdown I could
go on for those unfamiliar with the role
of design and product development
would you mind elaborating a little bit
sure happy to
really there's there's two primary roles
one is for the customer and that is
purely to help galvanize a team to
deliver something which is unexpectedly
fun and I use those words unexpectedly
fun very purposely because frankly when
you're when you're in an entertainment
industry and you're making a game or
you're playing that game it's very
challenging to you know beat the
expectation that somebody has when they
expect it to be fun and so you're really
trying to do something that livers that
little
bit of extra unexpected fun where it
makes people talk and they talk about
your game and like hey wait they did
what I wouldn't have expected they do
that I need to try that out and it's
really that that last little bit of
getting them something which they didn't
expect right like if you're gonna go
drive a Ferrari you're gonna expect to
be fast but you're not gonna expect the
guy next to you to you know hit the
button that busts out the booster
rockets on it and that's gonna be the
thing you remember because you weren't
expecting it right you were expecting it
to be great you expect him to be fast
but those booster rockets with a thing
that took it over the top and that's
really what you're trying to do on the
game trying to take that journey that
player on a journey and make them feel
something in the second role for design
really amongst the team you know it's
really regarded as the discipline that
helps tie everything together into
something pure something very focused
because there are there are times when
hey there might be business questions at
hand or tech questions or just design
questions themselves and designers are
really the ones pinned to hey here's
where this can go here's that vision
here's if this thing didn't go right
here's how we can pivot and still
deliver an X excellent customer
experience and in the end whether you're
an audio designer or game designer
combat designer or UX designer there's a
bunch of different flavors your job is
to deliver something focused pure and
that takes the player on a journey and
makes them feel something mm-hmm that's
good I feel like whenever I see you
design when you have this conversation
all the time in the office Chris it's
like good products start with good
designs so just I love having you on the
panel and it's gonna be a great
conversation so let's get started let's
get at this I know we all been waiting
for this Jason let's kick off with you
there was some big news this week on
xbox series X can you tell us how the
chances allow developers to unlock new
and innovative gaming experiences
absolutely you know this has been a
really exciting week for the team the
team's been working really hard on Xbox
series X since 2016 and to finally be
able to actually share some of the
details of what we've been working on
has definitely been a highlight for all
of us and you know as you mentioned on
Monday we shared many of the details of
our next-generation console and it's
really about enabling transformative
gaming experiences that we
never seen in the living room you know
in in the early days of the planning
process the design of the Xbox Series X
was really directly influenced by three
key principles like I mentioned before
first and foremost is developer and
gamer feedback when I was leading the
Xbox advance technology group you know
the team works closely with developers
all across the world making everything
from the industry's best blockbusters to
competitive eSports titles to extremely
innovative ideas in game design coming
from some of the industry's best
independent creators and we really
listened learned and helped them
overcome the technology barriers that
were really limiting their aspirations
for the games that they were creating
whether that was in hardware software or
even the developer tools that we provide
and then I think another key aspect of
it as well as gamers are also demanding
higher and more stable frame rates so we
challenge ourselves to not only build a
system that could reliably deliver high
quality 4k game experiences at 60 frames
a second but we challenge ourselves to
go even further and to deliver frame
rates up to 120 frames a second frame
reset historically you never thought
were possible in the living room you
know so it was really about kind of
pushing those boundaries and really
understanding what developers and gamers
were really looking for in a
next-generation console and then the
second one is just really looking at the
innovations in technology with an eye
towards the future you know everything
from advancements in CPU performance
more efficient usage of GPU
next-generation graphics innovation and
capabilities things like hardware
accelerated rate racing or variable rate
shading or mesh shaders it's really
about giving developers new kinds of
tools to really build those rich dynamic
worlds that players like to spend time
in and another great example of that is
with the current generation we're
basically at the upper bounds of what's
possible with a traditional rotational
drive technology and it was really
constraining the game design that
developers were having where they'd have
to arbitrarily funnel players through
different tunnels or pathways or you
you'd have a fast travel system where
I'd take a super long time to teleport
from one side of the map to another so
you know with these insights it was very
clear that we would need to invest in
things like SSD level IO performance or
a revolutionary new architecture to make
it easier for game developers and game
engines to stream assets in real time
from the storage solution into the
memory and the CPU and the GPU so that
you can get that real rich high fidelity
dynamic living world that players expect
and then I think the final principle or
the final thing that we really thought
about in the very early days was when
you design a new console hardware
platform you're really setting the
direction for gaming and game
development for the next seven to ten
years so you really have to have a solid
vision as to where you see game
development going and the kinds of
gaming experiences that players want to
have so as we looked into the future
with new innovations like project types
cloud and game streaming we knew we had
an opportunity to make key decisions in
the design of the system that would
could open up brand new possibilities
for developers and like one thing that
we learned very early on as we started
working closely with the azure team is
some of the same challenges that we have
in delivering a high-performance game
console in your living room are the same
kinds of challenges that we have in the
data center things such as delivering
high performance for gaming workloads
while minimizing power consumption and
thermal management and having that
vision of a future really helped shape
how we design our custom SOC that's
powering the Xbox Series X in the
overall system architecture so that we
could make sure that we're providing a
common and consistent hardware software
and development platform that makes it
easier for developers to bring the games
that they're developing today on console
and PC into the cloud in the future and
many of the technologies that were
innovating and incubating with the Xbox
series X are being brought to PC and
brought to a project X cloud and it's
because we designed the system with the
future in mind from the very outside of
the program Wow Jason is this is blowing
my mind like having worked on the team
for a while and
kind of getting a chance to see what
this thing looks like in person is kind
of like shocking right now this is
actually the first time I've actually
kind of I can't touch it my finger
prints will get on it it's one of those
things like this is amazing
I out about this all the time and you
said something that has really just like
blowing my mind a bit which is like this
is like one of the first times we've
built a console thinking about where the
next generation the next iteration the
next paradigm shift and game development
is really going and you talk about the
cloud can you touch a bit on the the
role that the cloud plays as you're
thinking about the development of Xbox
Series acts sure so you know there's
certain scenarios you know this is a
custom SOC this is a custom architecture
that we've designed from the ground up
to make sure that we're delivering that
high fidelity gaming experience but as
you think about things like the cloud
and what we're doing with Project X
cloud you know there's certain things
that for example virtualizing the
display controller as an example if
we're just designing the system in such
a way to make only a high-performing
gaming console that's an investment that
you wouldn't make or it's a design
decision you wouldn't really think about
but you only really get one chance to
make those decisions and it's when
you're designing the chip when you're
designing the overall system
architecture so as we think about how
developers are going to take their games
and move them to into the cloud or how
they're going to be developing games in
the cloud in the future we knew we
needed to invest in certain key
technological investments from day one
to make sure that we're providing a
clear path for developers so that
developers don't actually have to go in
like significantly alter their game or
rewrite their game from scratch we want
to provide kind of a path as game
streaming becomes much more much more
prevalent and accessible and ultimately
it's really about empowering developers
to reach customers all across the world
whether they choose to own a console
they choose to play on a PC or maybe
streaming is going to be their primary
experience we want to provide that easy
path for developers there's something
you said I'm one more follow question on
this and this is something that like a
lot of teams a lot of people that may be
watching this maybe just don't know is
the lead time
that it takes in order to to put
together a console can you talk to us a
little bit about like you mentioned
making technology decisions of what the
hardware is going to be in this box it's
not like oh it's it's two months from
launch let's just put this thing in
there like there's there's a whole
process to that thinking kid can you
elaborate just a little bit on on just
some of the work that it takes to kind
of think through where this is going to
be in time sure you know we really
started the development of Xbox series X
in 2016 before we even released the Xbox
one X so your point on lead times you
know it's multiple years of
Investigation of prototyping of trying
to figure out where the technology
roadmaps going understanding from
developers where what their game design
aspirations are you know there's an
entire new genres of games or new kinds
of game experiences that you know have
come up in the last two to three years
so a lot of it is really kind of that
partnership with our development
partners both at Xbox game studios as
well as the best creators all across the
industry but it's also making sure that
we have a clear vision of where do we
see gaming going as as team Xbox and
once again you know our goal is get
Katherine mentioned earlier you know
really reaching out to those two billion
gamers all across the world so it's like
how do we make it as easy as possible
and what are the investments that we
need to be making so that customers all
across the world can have the same great
gaming experience that those of us who
grew up gaming on consoles know and love
today and do it in such a way that makes
it easy for developers that's good
I think it's a perfect segue as well on
let's dig into the next bit of this we
want to talk a little bit about project
X cloud and Katherine I'm gonna bring
this next question to you would you mind
talking us through the approach of
Microsoft bringing project X cloud to
market and before you jump in I actually
I'm gonna get everybody follow me follow
me on the camera this gonna be fun we're
doing this in real time I have a server
blade over here from Project X cloud
that I also was so excited when I heard
this was going to be here this is an
actual project X cloud server blade that
is in the footprints of Azure
at the global data center level and it
is so cool to take a look at the guts of
this thing because Wow like the tech
that went into this myth the making of
this is unbelievably impressive
Catherine back to the question walk us
through Microsoft's approach in bringing
X cloud to market yeah absolutely Brian
when you just took off that no idea
where you were going but you're seeing
our blade and I mean it is so cool and
it is you know Rachel said it earlier
our products a testament to the amazing
teams that build them and you know
looking at this I just couldn't be more
proud so so going back to what we
believe the journey is we think we are
at the very beginning of a multi-year
journey with with streaming you know
there is much more we don't know about
streaming than we do know right now and
that's exactly why we came to market
with our preview plan where we where you
remember and it seems like an age ago
now but we started last October with
just four games in preview and since
then we've expanded countries we have
more than 90 games we've gone just from
Android we have test um an iOS test
flight running and as we talked about
before we will also be bringing this to
window tech Windows 10 pcs this really
is about a journey of us learning
together with the developer community
and to see the passion with which
developers have leaned into this with us
and the learnings that we're doing
together has just been mind-blowing it
just makes me so proud to be a part of
this team that's awesome and you
mentioned just a moment ago the the
response from some of the game
development community can you share a
little bit about like how has it been
working with game developers whatever
they would have been saying in in
building for Project X cloud yeah no
absolutely yeah you know what I'm
reminded actually back to a story we
spent a lot of time obviously talking
with developers before we launched into
preview and every time we would go to a
me
with a developer we would take their
game running on a mobile phone and hand
it to them to play and at that point
there was always silence in the room and
we kind of would look around the room
and think what's going on and start sort
of looking around the room and you know
talking to me talking to their teams and
saying well who worked on this and it
was very clear that no one had worked on
it because actually when you build for
Xbox you build for X cloud and what we
have done is just made the game work
automatically for them really and got it
up and running pretty much in a matter
of minutes and that first stage which we
call lift and shift literally taking a
game that you've built for Xbox and
putting it in the cloud literally blew
the developers away so so that's been
absolutely fascinating and then we've
just learned you know so much about how
gamers are using streaming and basically
you know we're seeing gamers play more
across the board which has been
fascinating for developers you know
they're not just playing for more on X
cloud they're also playing more on Xbox
and PC and specifically we're learning
about different sort of genre types and
what gamers whose stream their games are
enjoying perhaps more than others so it
really is a journey about us learning
together but we also are aware that
there are some developers who who want
to be doing more to optimize their games
for the cloud and in those circumstances
we really talk about it as cloud where
this is the work we're doing around
touch controls to support native
interaction or some of the api's that
we're developing that provide device
side characteristics so that developers
can optimize for the much smaller screen
size so as you can see it's literally
this this symbiotic journey that we're
on with our developers to really you
know begin to optimize this experience
you know when I when I talk to my team I
I really talk about you know the speed
of our learning cycles whenever you're
bringing a new technology to market it's
all about learning and the faster we
learn the better we're going to optimize
this product so so that's absolutely the
journey that we're on so good I always
I'm sitting in rooms with you like that
one of the things you say is we always
have to keep learning we always have to
keep improving I feel like that's really
the knee Phyllis that you've helped
bring that along with the team which is
just so good Chris let's pivot over to
you as a service and platform provider
what do you think Microsoft's role is
and helping game developers navigate new
technologies like Xbox series X and
Project X cloud frankly if it's two
words it's eliminating friction right I
mean the game game teams have a vision
for what they want to build and really
as a publisher your job is to let them
just execute on that and multiply the
effort against it and there are things
that sometimes are tricky to manage when
you're when you're a studio right large
or small sometimes business questions
come up and you you know you want to
sell things in a different way and the
publisher does it doesn't support that
and so it's it's how do you push that
and work with the publisher to get them
to offer things in different way
sometimes it's technology hey there's
this new tech we don't quite know what
to do with it or we have something and
we want you to push it even farther I
mean when I think about both X cloud and
the series X right more so than the GPU
as a game designer the game designs that
you can build because you might have a
much more powerful CPU is actually super
interesting because that's you know for
a while now we've been able to make
graphics and worlds that look very real
but the challenge frankly from a game
loop from a game dynamics perspective is
how do you make those worlds act real
right physics and AI and doing all of
the that math actually requires
a CPU that's pretty strong and so when
you think about kind of the typical
trade-offs that you've had in games in
the past or hey I can have you know a
small number of enemies that are really
really smart or a large number of
enemies that are not so smart you know
grunts that's always been a trade-off
that's limited what you can do in the
games and from the you know the fastest
thing to make a developer laugh is you
know as a designer you go into a room
and you tell them that you want to build
a scene where you're fighting in water
and you know you have you have a bunch
of these enemies and and everything
reacts dynamically the things getting
wet right they just look at you and
they're like yeah we can't do the
physics for that like you need you need
a CPU with some
or to do that and so moving forward on
something like series accent in the
cloud and understanding hey this isn't
just going to be something that we're
it's gonna look much better it's gonna
make that world feel and sound much more
real and we're gonna allow you to do
much much better things with physics
like simulations like those are the
things that are gonna allow games to
take a giant step forward and that's
really what I'm excited to do and as a
publisher I mean there's certainly the
bread-and-butter work we do you know
helping people understand the research
that we've done into different regions
if they want to know a customer that
they're not familiar with in a different
part of the globe understand what their
data pipeline and bandwidth is like in
that region understand where we think
the technology is going understand the
shell experiences that we're going to
build that are basically the stage for
their title right like they're building
this pearl and we're this at this Easter
to showcase that pearl and really the
publishers job is how do you eliminate
friction so that the game teams can just
draw in it what they're really good at
and we could help support them with
things that they shouldn't they
shouldn't have to care about right they
shouldn't have to care about building
tools to allow them to look at how to
optimize their engine and what's going
on in picks right they that's that
shouldn't be their job they shouldn't
have to worry about building giant data
centers across the planet right that
should be our job we can go do that they
should focus on the game what's going to
make it great and so simply put hey how
do we just make it easier for them and
allow them to turn things up that's good
and you you mentioned as you're talking
through this this idea of this awareness
and I think it's really interesting to
talk about what it means to have your
game be aware and I hear you guys talk
about this idea of this streaming aware
point of view maybe Jason can you can
you maybe elaborate a little bit on what
does it mean to be screaming aware
building a game streaming aware yeah so
like like Katherine was talking about
you know today with Project X cloud
we're we're kind of doing what we call
lift and shift which is taking existing
games that were already designed and
built for Xbox and being able to run
them in the cloud with the title not
even really being aware that it's
running in a remote data center but I
think there's a lot of power and
think there's a lot of opportunity if
the title actually knows whether not
it's being streamed or not and in this
case you know we enabled console
streaming on the Xbox one
today it's the same technology like if
you're actually streaming from either
your local console you're streaming from
Project X cloud what would you actually
change in your game so Catherine use the
example of if I know that my game is
actually streaming down to a mobile
device
maybe my I originally designed my HUD or
my UI for a 10-foot user experience on a
large screen TV but when I'm actually
streaming it to a mobile device maybe I
actually need to simplify the UI or
increase the font size so it's more
legible and easier to read you also
think about situations like multiplayer
like many multiplayer systems are
designed with this notion of network
latency and how do I keep people
together well if you knew that all your
game sessions were actually all running
in the same physical data center you
don't have to worry about ping times you
don't have to worry about Network
latency you know and one of the
technologies that we announced earlier
this week is dynamic latency input or
DLI not only did we build that so that
we will have the most precise and
responsive input possible if you're
playing a game in your living room say
it's a competitive eSports game or it's
a game that's running at 120 frames a
second where input latency really
matters but that same technology will
also be available in Project X cloud to
allow a developer to actually measure
their end end input latency so they can
actually optimize or customize the input
experience when they're actually
streaming to a mobile device versus when
you have a controller in your hands as
an example so once again when we really
think about the continuum in how do we
bring these things together as we design
and incubate and innovate in these
various technology arenas it's really
about putting the power and the control
in the developer's hands because they
know what's best for their players and
the game worlds that they're creating
and it's our job to provide the best
platform possible so that they can
deliver on that creative vision Wow so
good so good
I want to take that and I want to I'm
gonna turn the question a little bit and
Rachel let's go over to you for a bit um
this week there's a lot of news coming
out from gaming companies and you know
thinking about how people are
positioning hardware and cloud platforms
it's starting to feel like the story is
becoming this either-or narrative in
2020 Microsoft's gonna release both
project X cloud and Xbox Series X now
Rachel would you mind sharing a little
bit about like what is Microsoft's
thinking behind this yeah Brian I'm
happy to as we've mentioned you know
gamers and developers are truly at the
center of everything we do and for
gamers
you know our vision is for them to be
able to play the games they want with
the people they want wherever they want
and we know that our partnerships with
developers are key to delivering on this
mutual goal that we have so we're taking
our cues from gamers from developers and
as Catherine mentioned you know it is it
is valuable for us to get these
learnings and to constantly be learning
about that we know that gamers want more
games
they want to play with more people and
they are playing on more devices around
the world and we know that developers
are continually pushing boundaries
trying to reach more gamers around the
world who are playing on more devices
and more platforms and so the Xbox
Series X was really built for this
evolving landscape of gamers playing on
multiple multiple devices but also this
thing that we're seeing happening with
technology converging across console PC
and cloud we want both gamers and
developers to feel unconstrained in this
next generation of gaming and so we are
working with developers to unlock the
potential for what we can develop and
deliver to gamers together and so more
specifically from a developer
perspective
Jason touched on some of this in his
previous comments you know we're really
aiming to build Hardware that unleashes
their creative vision we're empowering
them to create how they want because
they know what's best for them and we're
providing the tools they need for now
and for the future so this enables them
to get their games to more gamers around
the world to more Xbox gamers
around the world whether they're playing
on Series X on PC or X cloud I think
it's it kind of sums it up you know the
question you asked about you know
either-or you know we believe that the
best experience for gamers and
developers is the experience that's
designed from day one so it's better
together so I think you could kind of
say our philosophy is an and philosophy
it's not an or philosophy you know we
will lead with the flagship experience
on our next-gen console and we will
extend that to players who want to play
on X phone you said something that's
super important which is this idea of
better together and I think that is like
a theme within just Microsoft and
Microsoft game stack it's this idea that
it's not an or statement but it's an and
statement letting game developers really
bring the tools that they're familiar
with and be able to work with the stuff
they love from Microsoft so I really
like that I'm curious Catherine you know
this idea of better together working on
project X cloud and Xbox Series X you
know from a cloud perspective what are
your thoughts on this this better
together story yeah absolutely I'm so
pleased you called on me bro because I
was I was going to add one thing to what
Rachel said which was so perfect it's
really about this idea of choice playing
your games wherever you choose to play
them and we just had such a great story
coming the other week from one of our
preview testers he's actually in the
Armed Forces and he's currently deployed
and he couldn't take his xbox with him
but he gets to play destiny 2 through
the X Cloud preview and I just think
that is so absolutely perfect and you
know and really speaks to reaching
people wherever they are and then I also
want to go through one point further
with that because you know we talked
earlier about reaching the 2 billion
gamers that demands
you know both both looking to the Xbox
world as we know it but also what we
call time expansion the total
addressable market that we can expand to
and you know as you know within preview
one of the markets will be coming to is
India where India is a huge gaming
nation today I think in fact I read
somewhere that it's
you know got the fifth most highly
engaged gamer population however it's a
market the weird Xbox don't know so well
so that is so fascinating as we work
with developers to say how can we bring
these great games that we're building to
new markets and new opportunities and I
really think that fits with the better
together that we take what we have and
we bring it to new places and new people
and new endpoints so it just couldn't be
a more exciting time to be part of the
team Xbox yeah and it's like there's
this whole kind of world where it's all
coming together and and Chris I almost
want to say ask the same question to you
is like you know when you think about it
from the design perspective building
better together is not simple anymore
just because you're having to deal with
so many different end points and so many
different customers and so many
different games talked a little bit
about like what is the role design in
this idea of thinking about multiple
products multiple platforms multiple
networks well a Katherine and Rachel's
point of our own choice when you look at
it from the player's perspective players
love games
what would they choose to do if you
handed them a time travel device right
which is effectively what you do when
you give somebody a cellular phone right
or something that they can take with
them because they can't always sit in
front of their PC or their laptop or
their console to play the game that they
so desperately want to play right
they'll get tattoos of their favorite
games right like they this is what they
want to do bar all else and when they
find themselves you know physically
standing in a line somewhere for five
minutes
three minutes two hours however long
it's going to be their mind is often on
that game and what better than have
their mind on that game but to actually
give them that wormhole give them that
tunnel so that they can spend that five
minutes or that 15 minutes whatever it
might be interacting with the game they
want to play and sometimes you know
through X cloud it's it's actually
playing it sometimes it's through things
like mixer what they're doing to watch
it and it's really designs for all to
allow you sometimes you want to play
sometimes you want to talk about that
game with your friends if you will have
a device with you or around you
throughout the day what role do those
devices serve and and designs job is to
make sure that it's helping people
connect
to the content and to the people that
they want to play that content with as
often as they can write as often as they
choose to because that player choice
right physically if I'm standing in that
line and checked out okay cool I want to
play a game I want to talk about that
game and if you give me a four minute
window to do it
amazing I'm in and so on the you know
certainly on the developer side you
think about well hey what does it mean
to build something that allows you to
play for you know a shorter amount of
time or to play it continuously kind of
throughout the day in small segments of
time not just for you know an hour or
six hours that you're gonna spend
sitting in front of your console your PC
and that's really what's amazing right
when you talk about better together it's
about how do you give people the choice
to participate in thing that they love
more often and and share that with more
people and certainly that was the goal
that we set out to accomplish and better
together really just means being super
attuned to letting gamers get closer to
the thing that they love you know
there's a wanting to plug real quick for
some content that we had that was pre
done before the show taped and it was
this X cloud talk that we have up on our
on-demand site so if you go to
aka.ms/offweb
that's up on our YouTube page on demand
there's some fascinating stuff that's
going on around the team and how they
think about building for the platform
and Chris I almost just want to ask a
real quick follow up on which is like
with regards to design itself what are
some of the challenges when trying to
design a UI or a UX that can map across
multiple devices oh there's a lot it for
the user I mean there's there's
literally like hey what's the type ramp
and how do you make it work in multiple
locations you know whether whether the
angular pixel density is different on a
10 foot screen than on something that's
you know a foot or two in front of you
right there's a bunch of just kind of
technical details related to design but
really when you think about what that UI
is there to do it's there to help
connect you and so the thing that might
be appropriate in terms of hey I want to
play right now and this is how I want to
interact with the game I love is
actually something different and you
might want to prevent present more of a
social view into that thing when you're
looking at it on a cell phone in a short
amount of time because that's actually
gonna be the thing that then sets you up
to play later in depth with your friends
right it's how do you catalyze that
group of people to get together when we
talk to we talk to gamers you know the
number one thing that they say is hey I
wish I could spend more time gaming I
just don't have enough time and and it's
even harder for me to find crossover
time with with my friends to play
together right that's the problem that
they would love help solving and so from
a UI perspective there's literally how
do you make this you know this UI look
good on a different end point and what I
need to take into account from a design
perspective but it's also what should I
be showcasing to the user because it
might not be that they want to play
right now it might want to be that there
are catalyzing a group to get together
to play later tonight and so having your
UI have an understanding of what a
player has been doing across your game
is really really important because then
you can showcase that even within the
game hey we notice you just finished you
know how are you gonna get on later
tonight or this weekend those are two
independent things but they're very much
both in designs wheelhouse to try and
fix and I think when you think about the
ecosystem that you're attached to moving
forward design is going to be
increasingly focused on how do I get
players access to the right thing at the
right time at the right moment because
certainly our job is to take care of
things like the type ramp so that when
you're looking at you know fonts on a on
a cell phone when they've been streamed
that they're actually as appropriate
there as they were on a 10 foot screen
right that's just stuff we need to take
care of awesome well let's take that
conversation a little bit and let's go a
little bit more into our journey with
developers now Jason this is a question
for you
given this is a year that we're shipping
both the console and a streaming
platform you know I'm curious Jason like
what is the approach Microsoft has taken
in the journey of working with game
developers and the katham we're gonna
also ask you the same question so hang
tight yeah it's actually kind of funny
because Katherine and I often do this
together because we really don't talk to
you or engage with developers just on
console or just
Project X cloud or what we're doing with
PC is an example we really kind of talk
to developers and lay out kind of our
vision for the future and how we can
help them deliver on the experiences
that they want to provide to their
players so that that means a consistent
hardware platform between what's
happening in the console ecosystem and
what's happening in the game streaming
side it's a common software platform
common api's the vast majority of the
code the game developers actually write
should be reusable across the cloud
across the console across PC so as we've
updated our API designs and our app
model we've really designed it so that
it can work across multiple devices and
then really where we want developers to
spend their time is focus on their game
making their game experience great so
that players have a great experience and
then really kind of tailoring it to the
unique capabilities of how they choose
to deliver it you know simple things
such as if I'm playing on a console
clearly I'm gonna you know prioritize or
lead with controller base input but if
the same game is being played on a PC
keyboard mouse is critically important
or maybe in a project xcode scenario
it's more about touch controls or making
it easier for for a player to play there
so you know it's actually been one of
the highlights for me over the last
three to four years is as we've been
developing these as we've been
challenging the teams internally on kind
of this next generation and how we think
about gaming and game development is
going out and actually talking to the
partners and you know hearing their
feedback you know telling them here's
where we see things are going getting
the feedback directly from them and then
adjusting and altering our plans because
at the end of the day you know we all
just want those same great gaming
experiences and as Rachel and Chris and
Katherine have said you know it's really
about making sure that the players all
across the world can have these same
great gaming experiences and doing it in
such a way that we make it as easy as
possible for developers that's awesome
and I almost want to touch on that again
- you said something that was really
interesting about working with
and it's this idea of like we have all
these developers who are coming and
watching game stock live right now when
are participating in their discord
channel following us on Twitter for
folks that are not currently working
with Microsoft today and they're wanting
to think about you know the next
generation of hardware the next
generation of streaming like what are
some advice some of the tips that you
give in and like hey this is what we've
experienced working with game developers
today here's some ideas of how to think
about that maybe Jason you could start
there and then Catherine I'm gonna come
over to you sure I think the core of it
is is honestly just keep building games
the way that you always have been
building games you know if you're
building a game on PC today we've made
it very easy to take a PC codebase and
get it running on console or getting it
running in the cloud we partner very
closely with all the industry's leading
middleware providers and engine
providers to make sure that they're
optimized to take full advantage of what
we deliver whether it's hardware
capabilities or some of the services
that we have with Xbox Live and Azure
play fab you know and it is really about
the the part that's really exciting
about this industry and part of the
reason why I love this industry is it's
the marrying of creativity and
technology and that's the thing that the
the game developers all across the world
whether it's you know the largest studio
is working on a triple a blockbuster or
small you know super creative
independent creators
it's about the creativity and it's about
the worlds that you want to create in
the experiences that you want to deliver
to players and it's our job at Team Xbox
to really remove the technology and make
the technology fade away in the
background and developers are just
really focused on creating that
immersive experience that players want
to spend time in hmm that's good
Catherine how would you say the same
thing you know like what are your
experiences and what are your thoughts
on how a game developer should think
about building for this next generation
of hardware building for this next
generation of streaming yeah you know
Jason said it so beautifully we often go
out together and exactly what just
happened happens Jason just says it's so
beautifully that I just kind of need to
go it's what he said but but I'll try
and add to that in that you know as we
as we talked about before this first
step of the journey that we think that
we think we're on is what we're calling
lyft and Shepherd it's the convenience
of developing for the Xbox that then
magically works in the cloud and that's
a really important first step and then
Jason took us through it earlier and I
also talked to some of the touch
controls and api's were talking we're
building around sort of providing more
information about whether the game is
streaming and that has been the next
piece which is the cloud aware keys
which just allows us to optimize games
an important point that we probably
haven't touched on so far but is
absolutely something that thinking about
is this concept of what we're calling
cloud native games these are games that
no longer just reduce the resources of
the top of the local device but parlous
the full power of the cloud and it's so
fascinating before you know the world
got stopped by the coronavirus I had an
incredible trip to Japan and Korea
meeting with ton of developers you know
and so fascinating to see how people
were leaning in to really understanding
how the cloud could actually change the
process of development the iteration of
development when team sat to develop as
well as then and I think it was Chris
who mentioned it earlier this idea of
frictionless play and therefore what
that meant for the numbers of people who
could play together or even some of the
business models and monetization of
games and what we're really seeing here
is just creativity unleashed you know as
Jason just said it's our job to put the
technology somewhere behind so that
others can just leverage it and our
vision is for developers to be able to
really leverage the true power of the of
the cloud and we're not just seeing this
excitement with some of our larger
developers I am just it's incredible the
support we've had from Chris Charlie's
ID and Xbox program and the indie
developers and our message to those
developers is really clear we just want
you to focus on your games and your
gameplay you know don't worry about
porting it to other platforms we're
gonna take care of
between the console and the cloud we're
gonna take care of that for you and so
that's what I think is so exciting about
this period and that's that's the energy
we get as we meet with the developers is
that this period is about literally this
unleashing of creativity and that can
only be great for gamers so something
that you know a lot of people outside of
Microsoft get a chance to hear which is
just like some of the high-level
thinking's some of the philosophies
behind why we're doing this and
Katherine could you maybe touch on just
for a second like where do we see this
all going we always talk about how we
want to put the gamer at the center and
we want to make sure that they can play
the games they want on the devices they
want with the people they want like how
does this all kind of play into the
larger mission that Microsoft yeah no
well I don't know that I can speak to
the larger mission of Microsoft but I
can certainly speak to how we view the
vision as a team which is it's all about
ubiquity your game should be available
to play on any device at any point that
that you choose to play and the
community and all your saves and
everything else related to the game just
comes with you I mean think about it
we've seen this in in video you know you
can watch your Netflix you know I mean I
I personally choose and everybody scoffs
of me but I personally choose to watch
most of my movies on my phone but
obviously you can watch it on any device
that you choose and I really think this
concept of ubiquity is absolutely key
it's about reaching every platform and
it's about us you know for developers as
I said before really leveraging the
cloud and through our partners with
Azure which is you know as we know one
of the world's leading cloud with you
know with huge geographical footprint to
really allow us to reach gamers who
previously it was much harder for us to
reach with this fidelity of games so
that's really our high-level vision
that's good and you know I think in
talking with a lot of these developers
especially as they're starting to kind
of get to the next stage one of the
questions that you know I think a lot of
people who are not necessarily engaged
with Microsoft today around Xbox Series
X or project X cloud is for developers
who are sitting on the fence
maybe Rachel if you could answer like
what would you say to a developer who's
kind of like looking at this technology
and saying like I don't know which when
when is the right time to get involved
you think it's a lot of like Catherine
and Jason touched on jump in right you
know I think back to when we started our
indie game studio seems like a lifetime
ago you know there were three of us we
didn't know what we didn't know and that
actually enabled us to go do really
awesome things and for us a team at
spots you know we truly love hearing
those ideas and seeing what developers
can create because we're not going to
tell you what to do and we shouldn't
tell you what to do you're gonna tell us
right and so if I you know put myself in
you know my own shoes
a long time ago and well-aged myself you
know I think it would just be Joe Ben
right Joe then work with us a reach out
to us help us learn what we don't know
help us figure out that to reduce that
friction to help you be able to deliver
those creative visions you know
especially with as we think about you
know developing for both console and
cloud the cloud space is so exciting I
don't think we even know what that's
gonna look like you know I I always
talked to the team about you know
watching my children play they play
together
they're on multiple devices they're
constantly going back and forth between
devices and it's where their friends are
is where they go I think when when we
think about the opportunity across all
these platforms and all these devices
that's what Xbox wants to bring to
developers the ability to reach gamers
where we see them going and so jump in
that's good so let's talk real quick
about some of the key learnings that
we've gotten from development partner is
during the you know the work that we've
done to build our Xbox Series X and
project X cloud I always love the fact
of like it's great to hear what's going
well what are some challenges that
people just have in general building for
the cloud and and building for a new new
technology Jason let's go to you sure so
so you know I think one of the things
that's exciting about the transition of
a generation is what you used to think
of previously as constraints many times
they go away
you know I mentioned like the IO system
and the fact that we're at the upper
bounds of what's possible with a
rotational Drive now that that's no
longer a barrier it opens up all these
new possibilities but then Olson we're
gonna discover kind of some of the next
challenges you know it's like now I have
almost you know kind of unlimited memory
and I can feed it into the system but
now all sudden you know certain
limitations we previously counted on no
longer exists and I think that
challenges a lot of preconceived notions
so I think there's that and I think the
other thing too is just you know with
you know there's times where there's a
member of the team who she mentioned you
know with Xbox one X it was like getting
a playground to play with and then with
something like Xbox Series X now the
team has an entire amusement park to
play with so it can be a little bit
overwhelming to actually figure out like
where do I want to invest you know what
are these new opportunities that I have
so I think the real guidance that I'd
give to developers in the community out
there is you know challenge yourselves
think creatively what is that what is
the gaming experience you always wanted
to build and you know a little bit to
what we've talked about throughout today
you know if there's ever something where
you know the software is not enabling
you to do it or the developer
development tools would be more useful
if they did this or my iteration time
needs to improve we want that feedback
we need that feedback we absolutely
listen to that feedback and it
fundamentally shifts the direction that
we go so we listen very closely to the
gaming community we're all gamers
ourselves we all play on Xbox Live
almost every day we have family members
that we play with and we connect with
but it's also true with developers as
well you know we want to know where
we've gotten it right we want to know
where you're struggling and it's our
challenge then is to take that feedback
and go away and come up with really
creative solutions that meets the needs
of the development community so that you
guys can just focus on delivering that
amazing gaming experience that all of us
can't wait to actually play so
that's so good all right I think we're
getting tight on time so we're gonna do
what's called the lightning round we
have a set of questions they're gonna
ask every single person here what are
the most important things for a game
developer to take away from this
conversation today Rachel let's start
with you okay I'll try to be super quick
since you said we're tight on time I
think my hope is that the biggest one of
the biggest takeaways from today is the
feeling of excitement you know as we've
mentioned you know we're in the midst of
something you know very crazy
unprecedented going on in the world
there's a lot of heaviness I hope that
anybody listening whether it was a
developer a gamer maybe a student
supposed to be doing remote learning
that they feel that lighted inside of
them that they feel that passion that we
all have for gaming I hope they're
excited excited about the future excited
about our next gen hardware and software
excited about you know how we can do
things together and the things we're
gonna build together to reach gamers
around the world so they can play watch
communicate and create together that's
good that's good Chris let's go over to
you what is the most important thing a
game developer should take away from
this conversation you know I was really
hoping to talk about what we've learned
in relation to input and skill ceiling
right like if we you tell everybody hey
we're gonna pack a stadium with people
to go watch tic-tac-toe that wouldn't be
the case because the world championship
of tic-tac-toe is gonna be boring
because there's no skill ceiling right
it always comes out as a tie and as
we've gone down this route and looked at
what the new generation of people
growing up learning how to use you know
play games on glass natively which is
it's different than certainly how I grew
up you know playing games on mouse and
keyboard with the controller people can
play games on glass to a degree and a
fidelity which allows a skill ceiling
which is actually pretty incredible and
it was you know two years ago when we
kicked off our journey looking at that I
didn't think that was going to be the
case and now that we've looked at it
both on the customer side and what the
best kind of game developers on the
planet are doing people are really
solving the skill problem or the skill
ceiling problem so when you think about
pushing a game out I would not be
worried about thinking about a phone
perhaps is the lowest
common denominator be confident that you
can actually make the game that you've
built originally you know when you think
about a PC era console you can make that
skill ceiling you can make that thing
excellent no matter where it's being
streamed to that's good all right
Catherine let's go to you what is the
most important thing that a developer
can take away from this conversation
today
yeah yeah absolutely what I would say is
look embrace the the new be open to
learning and don't constrain your
thinking by frameworks that have existed
in gaming previously I think we're in a
period where we are rewriting the rules
of traditional game development and I
think that's such an exciting period
with huge opportunity and the only way
that we can really you know leverage
that is by being open to any amount of
possibilities and just increasing those
learning cycles so be open to the new
that's my main takeaway that's good and
Jason what is the most important thing a
developer can take away from today's
conversation it's kind of funny I'm like
Catherine everybody else said it so
eloquently I don't know how much more I
can add I guess the only thing that I
would add to what everybody else has
really talked about is just focus on the
player focus on the gamer just really
focus on how can you delight that player
you know the the need to play is just a
fundamental human condition and that's
why I think many of us work in this
industry and we love this industry
because at the end of the day our job is
great fun and there's nothing better to
do and so as long as you're focusing on
the player we're here to help in any way
that we can we want the feedback from
the community both players and
developers but as long as you're
focusing on the player I don't think you
can really go wrong that's good man so
good well thank you guys so very much
for joining over the phone it has been
an awesome chance to talk with this
that's it for us Malik Kelly over to you
anyway thanks Brian well Kelly if you
wanted to know more about next-gen
hardware and what it can do in the cloud
we can all cross it off the list right
now indeed indeed I could not be more
excited and that was such a great
conversation what do you guys think and
look what do you think well I think I
think this is an exciting period in time
next-gen hardware Xbox series X coming
out this year holiday 2020 can't just
say it has Xbox series X that's true
that's true
anyway sorry you're right Xbox series X
thank you so everyone out there head
over to our discord and let us know what
you think about it and and tell us about
all the things Xbox news X and X cloud
which I'm super excited about in any
event in fact we've got some teams from
our some of our favorite games in chat
as well that's right like Age of Empires
I'm so excited that's actually my
favorite game of all time
Age of Empires 2 specifically yeah it's
a great game it actually caused me to
kind of get into gaming and to do what I
do right now kind of love strategy games
wololo right isn't that the thing you
knew you knew it exactly now Malik we've
seen a ton already over the last two
days panels with industry leaders
conversations with studio directors and
even some ID and Xbox pros what has been
your highlight and why has it been a
panel that we just saw Xcode you know
what I was gonna say I think I kind of
gave it away that that was the most
exciting I think again I am we said at
the beginning of yesterday a lifelong
Xbox fan and one of the things that I've
always dreamed about it's being at
Microsoft during the launch of a new
console and Xbox Series X coming off
this year is gonna be fantastic
as we heard on the last panel the focus
on performance speed and of course
compatibility the idea that you're gonna
have thousands of games from previous
Xbox generations playable on your
console the SSD which is brand-new for a
new generation of consoles first-ever
generation that's going to have an SSD
built in to the console and of course
just twelve teraflops of GPU power
twelve teraflops fun saying that right
exactly exactly so yeah Oh Kelly what
was your highlight though oh I really
liked the accessibility conversations
that we got to have yesterday and like
just learning about live ops and live
services it's incredible just learning
kind of what game stack is
if there's any developers out there that
are just kind of joining right now and
don't know what it is check out
games.com also our YouTube is gonna have
vods available of all of the talks and
panels that we've had over the last two
days so if you did miss it if you're
just joining us right now do not fret
everyone because all that will be
available soon and I believe they keep
saying soon with like maybe a teams yeah
yes auntie em cuz you know whose pet
who's ever to say when something's gonna
happen and then one thing that I've
loved over these last two days is
talking to you and you said a lot let's
check out what you said in out here our
last panel on next-gen gaming featured
Xboxes partner director of program
management jason ronald and due to
technical issues brought on by our
remote interviews we had to use head
headshots and someone has taken jason's
and dr at the bit a huge thanks to end
rivo for this let's take a look at this
okay so Jason let me just say something
wait so Jason has one of the most
glorious beards I've ever seen it it
morally is like the paddling the pattern
of it how like half of its gray half of
its dark we also have that strip of grey
down the dark like it's really cool it's
very very deliberate and very regal I
don't know what the word would be I
don't know but it's really cool to see
he's just perching over Xbox because he
is literally the guy who's put
everything together and so along with
obviously a great team and so this is
really cool to see I think we have a few
more tweets in fact so let's see what
we've got
I do think that was to scale though the
picture option yeah it's gonna you know
it kind of actually it doubles as a
heater for your house it doubles is a
lot right yeah I think it's funny
because Xbox actually tweeted out a
picture on Monday of you know to scale
an Xbox Series X console next to a
fridge so it's really it's really funny
alright so we have another tweet from
one of our Xbox MVPs in fact this is
Simon Darkseid it says my favorite quote
from the team let's look back at here
because this is easier to see my
favorite quote from the team at game
stack live today is this something else
you should know the same team that
solved the amazing technical feat of
Xbox 360 back and Pat is also the team
that created GME project X cloud
awesomeness to the max a hundred percent
so just to give a note on that back in
May 2015 we announced Xbox 360 backward
compatibility
xbox1 something that wasn't possible but
thanks to the amazing engineers and
teams here at Xbox we were able to make
it happen and so they are working on
Project X cloud it's gonna be fantastic
lots of solutions but I'm super excited
to see how it really is exciting just to
like how how gaming and game development
alike like evolves every every iteration
every generation there's something new
that they had something incredible with
the teams that we have here I'm really
excited although you know we were
talking about our favorite parts of
today I think actually my favorite part
might be this next conversation that
you're gonna be having with double fun
or a huge fan Grim Fandango you have
Psychonauts - that's coming out this
year and then of course I think brutal
legend does not get as much love as it
deserves here well let's go back on to
our tweets here Xbox series X + project
x cloud equals new chapter and game a
new chapter and the evolution that's
pretty much what I was saying you
chinkyu
nes bot feat what oh it's not a bot okay
oh okay
didrik re pay to get his tweet up here
unbelievable a little bit back in the
production phase like you guys better
put this up there you go show me
although it is really cool the shoes
with a shirt and I do believe that we
yesterday heard that some people were
asking how do we get these shirts how do
i how do i get this jacket well I don't
know that's the answer on the sales
let's Kelly have an answer I don't know
you know if you complain enough maybe
something will happen maybe something
will happen all I got to say is that
work REI I heard it in my ear that
require I definitely did pay for this
free promotion in which case I would
like to know how much that cost because
I would like to do that as well anyway
oh well everyone now it's time to check
out one of the most creative ecosystems
in the gaming industry that has helped
propel a dev team to gaming glory here
now what drives dub fine if we're making
a list of priorities for the company the
word at the top of the list would be
creativity that's something we like to
see in every game that we make and
everything that we do whether it's our
business or her you know I don't want
say creative finances
hook boys sounds bad
[Music]
a game shouldn't just be one person's
vision there's always going to be
something in like a double fun project
that will appeal to like a very wide
variety of people because we have such a
wide variety of people making that
content here that's just what makes our
getting special Double Fine games they
feel like they're made by humans that's
something that I think leads to a unique
feeling in our in our games thinking
outside of the box access to a
counterculture you may not necessarily
see in games that people come to Double
Fine to play games that are different
and unique I started the company because
I had an idea for a game Psychonauts it
struck me at a certain point that the
game of doing my ideas for ten years and
there were so many creative people at
the company how do we get everybody's
ideas to the forefront so we took a
break during Bert Legend and we split
the whole company 60 people into four
smaller teams and we just seemed crazy
at the time the first well we're gonna
stop working on this game which is it's
not like it's ahead of schedule we're
gonna make a game in two weeks that
sounds crazy but out of it came these
amazing little game demos and we liked
it so much we do